l'événement sportif de la semaine à
venir c'est à bercy le tennis réunissant
les plus grands champions du moment
aujourd'hui à la veille de la
compétition
plusieurs d'entre eux étaient venus
donner un coup de main à yannick noah et
à son association les enfants de la
terre françois brabant maryse richard
c'est bien connu
le tennis est un jeu d'enfant et pour
les enfants de la terre des enfants
il y en avait partout à bercy cet après
midi jusque sur la chaise d'andré agassi
bref ça beau être les vacances bercy
ressemble à une vraie cour de récréation
c'est la première fois que les knicks
noir occupent bercy à la veille du
tournoi pour récolter des fonds pour son
association forcément une première
farran un peu nerveux d'autant qu'en
face ils s'y sont mis à plusieurs et qu'
ils sont pas là pour rigoler
mais eux aussi à chercher de l'aide dans
le public depuis les tribunes wilfried
n'arrêtait pas de le conseiller
non à lui a demandé donc de le rejoindre
sur le court et n'a pas eu à le
regretter
à eux deux yannick et wilfrid banderille
est un nouveau tandem au plus haut
niveau est né il faut que j'en parle à
la fédération on ne sait pas si le
report ce que tu veux avec mon coach
mouassa serait pas de problème surtout
que bon moment j'ai préparé tout un
programme
demain les choses sérieuses pourront
commencer bercy c'est le tournoi le plus
riche du monde le plus important de
cette fin de saison pur courrier hedberg
boetsch et les autres
mais aujourd'hui au moins le tennis est
redevenu ce qu'il aurait dû toujours
être un jeu d'enfant